♪
>> Geraldo: HEY, EVERYBODY.
WELCOME BACK.
STILL CELEBRATING AMERICAN
FREEDOM AND OF COURSE MY 78TH
BIRTHDAY.
SOME DEMOCRATS AND PROGRESSIVE
MEDIA ALLIES HAVE TURNED THIS
FOURTH OF JULY INTO A BASH
AMERICA FEST.
CORI BUSH IS AN EXAMPLE TWEETING
"WHEN THEY SAY THE
FOURTH OF JULY IS ABOUT AMERICAN
FREEDOM, REMEMBER THIS, THE
FREEDOM THEY ARE REFERRING TO IS
FOR WHITE PEOPLE.
THIS LAND IS STOLEN, STOLEN LAND
AND BLACK PEOPLE STILL AREN'T
FREE."
MAXINE WATERS ADDS TWEETING "THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE SAYS
ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL.
EQUAL TO WHAT?
ONLY WHITE MEN."
IT WASN'T JUST CONGRESS, MEDIA
OUTLETS, AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," ET CETERA
ALSO TAKING SHOTS AT AMERICA.
IT'S NOT A PERFECT COUNTRY BUT
EVERY PLACE I TRAVEL, PEOPLE
WANT TO COME HERE.
>> Greg: I UNDERSTAND THIS IS
FROM STUDENTS.
IF YOU ARE IN COLLEGE, YOU HAVE
THE PEER PRESSURE AND PROFESSORS
THAT ARE CONSTANTLY FEEDING YOU
THIS GARBAGE, RIGHT?
IT'S WHEN YOU GET OUT OF
COLLEGE, SUDDENLY YOU REALIZE
THAT IT'S GARBAGE AND THIS IS A
GREAT PLACE.
I GET A PAYCHECK.
I CAN SAVE MONEY.
I CAN WORK.
THERE'S ALL THIS OPPORTUNITY.
BUT THESE ARE POLITICIANS.
THESE ARE "OUR LEADERS."
AND THE BELIEF IN THE MEDIA IS
THAT NO ONE WILL TAKE YOU
SERIOUSLY IF YOU ARE A
PATRIOTIC.
IF YOU ARE PATRIOTIC, IT'S A DOG
WHISTLE FOR EXTREMISM.
IT'S ACTUALLY EXCLUSIONARY TO
ACTUALLY LOVE YOUR COUNTRY.
IT'S FLIPPED.
WHEN WE WERE YOUNGER, BEING
PATRIOTIC WAS THE NORM AND
BURNING A FLAG WAS RISKY.
NOW IT'S COMPLETELY REVERSED.
IF YOU WANT TO BE ACCEPTED IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY, IN
MEDIA, IN ACADEMIA, YOU HAVE TO
TRASH THIS COUNTRY.
HOWEVER, NONE OF THESE CRITICS
WOULD GO ANYWHERE ELSE.
THEY LOVE WHAT THEY GET.
THEY LOVE ALL THE BENEFITS FROM
TRASHING THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE
THAT IS WHAT AMERICA IS.
BUT THEY ARE ALL COME IN MY VIEW
THEY ARE DISGUSTING.
>> Geraldo: BE THAT AS IT MAY,
IT IS VERY FASHIONABLE TO
CRITICIZE AMERICA.
MOST DISTURBINGLY TO ME, THE
AMERICAN FLAG, WHICH WAS THIS
ICON OF RESPECT AND AFFECTION,
AND SOMETHING THAT BROUGHT US
ALL TOGETHER.
IT HAS SUDDENLY BECOME JUST
ANOTHER PART OF SOME KIND OF
ICON TO THROW AROUND.
>> Dana: REMEMBER, THEY ARE
SAYING THESE THINGS AS THEY ARE
SITTING MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
ELECTED TO CONGRESS, PAID BY THE
UNITED STATES TAXPAYER, TAXPAYER
DOLLARS IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
HAVE A SALARY, WELL, MAXINE
WATERS MIGHT BE A DIFFERENT
STORY WHEN WE LOOK INTO THAT
FINANCIAL SITUATION.
YOU HAVE A CHOICE OF HOW YOU
WANT TO CONDUCT YOURSELF.
WHEN I THINK IS HAPPENING HERE
IS IT'S FASHIONABLE BUT IT ALSO
MAKES THEM MONEY.
IF YOU BASH AMERICA, IT'S GREAT
FOR RETWEETS ON TWITTER.
AND THEN YOU CAN USE THAT FOR
FUND-RAISING.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
JUST IGNORE THAT.
DON'T FEED INTO THAT.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A BETTER
THING.
THE THING THAT REALLY BOTHERS ME
IS THEY WILL DO THINGS LIKE THIS
AND THEN THEY WILL TURN AROUND
IN THE NEXT BREATH AND THEY WILL
SAY, WELL, HOW WOULD YOU DO
POLARIZE AMERICA?
AS IF IT WAS ON THE PEOPLE WHO
FEEL PATRIOTIC.
>> Geraldo: AND JESSIE, IT'S
TRUE THAT THE COUNTRY AS A PLACE
WHERE THERE IS TREMENDOUS
INEQUALITY.
HOWEVER OPEN, FAIR, FREE AND THE
REST OF IT, AND WE ALWAYS BRAG
ON IT, YOU KNOW, I LIVE IN
CLEVELAND, ONE OF THE POOREST
CITIES IN AMERICA, AND ALMOST
EVERYBODY LIVING IN THOSE
HORRIBLE NEIGHBORHOODS IS BLACK.
>> Jesse: WHILE YOU CAN ALSO
SAY GOOD THINGS ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE PICKING
SCABS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THAT'S ALSO A GOOD ADVICE, HELLO
SHE SAYS THIS LAND WAS STOLEN.
THIS LAND WASN'T STOLEN.
WE WON THIS LAND ON THE
BATTLEFIELD AND WE BOUGHT IT.
RIGHT?
WE PURCHASED SPAIN.
I MEAN WE PURCHASED FLORIDA FROM
SPAIN.
WE HAVE THE RECEIPTS.
WHAT, DO YOU WANT TO GIVE
FLORIDA BACK TO SPAIN?
>> Greg: HOW ABOUT THE
SEMINOLES?
>> Jesse: WHAT ABOUT IT,
GERALDO?
WE WON THAT TERRITORY ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
IT WAS AN UGLY BRUTAL BATTLE BUT
WE WON IT.
WE ARE NOT JUST GOING TO GIVE
EVERYTHING BACK TO THE
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
NO CIVILIZATION, WHAT, DID THE
MOORS COME INTO SPAIN AND
CONQUER THEM FOR 800 YEARS AND
PEOPLE SAY OH, LET'S JUST GIVE
IT BACK TO SPAIN?
THIS IS NOT REALITY.
THE OTHER THING SHE SAID WAS
THIS.
SHE SAID THAT BLACK PEOPLE ARE
NOT FREE.
WHERE?
SHE REPRESENTS ST. LOUIS,
GERALDO.
THEY HAVE A BLACK POLICE CHIEF,
MAYOR, NDA IN ST. LOUIS.
AND THEY HAVE A BLACK
CONGRESSWOMAN.
SO ARE YOU SAYING THESE
BLACK LEADERS ARE TO NINE
FREEDOM TO THE BLACK PEOPLE OF
ST. LOUIS CLUSTER MARK THAT'S
INSANE.
SO WHAT SHE IS DOING IS SHE IS
TRAFFICKING HATRED FOR MONEY.
I LOOKED AT HER WEBSITE.
IT'S REPARATIONS, D PHONED THE
POLICE, AND TO THE PRISONS,
LEGALIZE CRACK.
I FEEL SORRY FOR HER DISTRICT
BECAUSE SHE IS NOT SERVING THE
INTERESTS OF HER DISTRICT.
IF SHE AND I WERE TO HAVE DINNER
TOGETHER, I THINK SHE WOULD LIKE
ME.
I REALLY DO.
I THINK I COULD CONVINCE HER
THAT WE WERE GOOD FRIENDS.
>> Greg: SHE IS LIKE YOUR MOM.
>> Katie: SEND IT TO HER
OFFICE.
>> Geraldo: WE HAVE
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS,
THE FIRST WOMAN, FIRST BLACK
WOMAN.
BARACK OBAMA, HISTORIC FIGURE.
AND YET, IT SEEMS AS IF THE
DIVISION SINCE BARACK OBAMA'S
TENURE HAS ONLY GOTTEN MORE
EGREGIOUS.
>> Katie: I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT WHO IS
DOING THE DIVIDING, WHO IS
STOKING THAT DIVISION.
WHEN CONGRESSWOMAN BUSH SAYS
THAT BLACK PEOPLE STILL AREN'T
FREE, I THINK IT REALLY
UNDERMINES THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF BLACK AMERICANS.
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE,
CLARENCE THOMAS FOR EXAMPLE.
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA, LARRY
ELDER, BEN CARSON, ONE OF THE
BEST SURGEONS THE WORLD HAS EVER
KNOWN.
THIS IDEA THAT THEY ARE
DOWNPLAYING ALL OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THESE PEOPLE
TO KEEP UP THIS DIVISIVE
NARRATIVE, GET SOME RETWEETS,
MAYBE GET SOME CARD-CARRYING
MEMBER OF THE NEW SQUAD IN THE
HOUSE.
IT REALLY DOWNPLAYS NOT JUST THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE AS A
COUNTRY, BUT ALSO THE PROGRESS
THAT AMERICAN, BLACK AMERICANS
HAVE MADE FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND FOR THEIR COUNTRY WHEN IT
COMES TO FIXING WHAT YOU SAY IS
INEQUALITY IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
I RECOMMEND PEOPLE READ "WHITE
GUILT."
IT TALKS ABOUT THESE PROBLEMS
THAT HAVE PERSISTED FOR DECADES
UNDER BLACK LEADERSHIP.
THAT IS SOMETHING I THINK PEOPLE
HAVE TO START TALKING ABOUT.
>> Geraldo: I ALSO THINK THAT
THE GREATEST CIVIL RIGHT IS A
JOB WITH THE POSSIBILITY FOR
PROMOTION AND OTHER BENEFITS.
I BELIEVE IN FREE ENTERPRISE
SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW, IT IS, I JUST WANT TO
QUICKLY SAY, TO YOUR POINTS, ANY
TIME I CRITICIZE ANY OF YOU, I
GET PICKED UP IN THE VARIOUS
MEDIA.
THAT'S A RECIPE --
>> Dana: WE KNO